il s'est engagé à la légion il ya 13 ans
dès qu'il en a l'occasion il prend un
peu le large
j'aime bien lire en fête ce jeu je lis
souvent n'a pas tout ni porter mais que
j'ai un petit peu de ton jeu bien le
dire il a su faire de l'évasion
alors que tu as déjà au bout du monde
c'est impossible de s'échapper des soi
même alexandre a vécu un drame terrible
il a perdu un enfant alors il s'est
engagé dans la légion j'avais presque
tweed un coup j'ai perdu presque tous
quoi aussi et puis j'avais une famille
j'avais une fille donc d'un coup j'ai
perdu tout et puis c'était difficile
pour moi quoi jeter et
j'essayais d'échappement des mois même
la suite de l'accident de suite
damas les maladies c'était une manière
d'oublier aussi oui mais tu n'as pas
oublié non
[Musique]
avec pudeur alexandre a accepté de se
confier
mais ce n'est pas souvent le cas la
légion ici chacun a son histoire sa part
de mystère
ces hommes ont tous quitté et accepte de
donner leur vie pour la france un pays
qui n'est pas le leur le producteur qui
déboule quelques siècles en picard qui
déboule on est prêt même à trente six
arrivées sur la première on a fouillé le
sergent raul déploie son groupe cette
saison
le but c'est de trouver espèce de zone
de pibrac donc s'il n'eut jamais vous
voyez quelque chose suspects des boîtes
de conserves nouvelles sur sa tablette
le capitaine du génie reçoit des
informations préoccupantes les collines
serait mines et les hommes sont sur
leurs gardes
les sapeurs ont repéré un objet blanc
le capitaine des mineurs savant seul
face à l'objet suspect il a accepté de
filmer la scène
ok mais un peu bizarre
il a deux minutes pour s'éloigner du
câble si on la deuxième zone inspectés
nous retrouvons marcel l'infirmier
cherche à mana 1.1.1 williana il ya une
cage normalement donc on a les
coordonnées gps de 7 points ici à
première vue il n'y a rien d'autre que
du sable pourtant d'après le
renseignement
ce serait un point de ravitaillement
quelque part sous cette dune les
terroristes ont enfoui du matériel avec
leurs détecteurs de métaux les soldats
cherchent des armes des émetteurs radio
des équipements informatiques sous le
sable il y a quelques mois ils ont fait
une trouvaille surprenante à trouver des
petits tubes intérêts en plein milieu du
désert puis cap entier avec des pièces à
l'intérieur non comme on sait que ils
peuvent ils peuvent cacher des endroits
probable 20 ans continue on cherchera
une fouille minutieuse qui au bout de 20
minutes fini par payer
je savais que j'ai fait mon boulot sous
7 euros de secours
protégé par des bâches en plastique
comme cela il y a les provisions des
terroristes ça c'est la semoule céder
t&d celles passées les gens et les
choses pour les gens il s'arrête à
essayer projet du thé du riz de l'huile
de quoi nourrir un groupe de combat est
ce qu'il faut au niveau au niveau
nourriture donc ils peuvent voyager dans
des airs s'arrêter six voiliers sont à
l'abri s'approvisionner en essence du
bois que récupérer la nourriture et
repartir
les légionnaires décide de tout brûler
plus loin il découvre une douzaine de
bidons les terroristes s'en servent
habituellement pour stocker de l'essence
cette fois ils sont vides mais les
légionnaires les détruise pour éviter
qu'ils ne soient réutilisées trois
semaines plus tard près de la passe de
salvador
les hommes du colonel monnier ont été
pris dans un violent accrochage qui les
a opposés à les trafiquants la fouille
du véhicule a permis la saisie d'armes
de guerre des fusils mitrailleurs des
kalachnikov des munitions des moyens de
communication et une tonne 5 de cannabis
trois trafiquants ont été tuées trois
autres faits prisonniers et remis aux
forces armées nigériennes aujourd'hui 9
100 légionnaires sont engagés pour la
france en opération à travers le monde